It's great to welcome back to the program.
Jeff Cohen, who's a journalist and media critic,
founder of fairness and accuracy
in reporting and cofounder of roots action,
which has identified 15 house members that
it considers to be ripe targets for progressive
primary challenges.
I think Jeff, for reasons that I'll explain
shortly, my audience will be pleased to hear
me talking about this.
So, I mean, let, let's just talk first about
the, the general principle.
In other words, how should we be thinking
of when it makes sense to invest resources
in primaries?
A seat currently held by a Democrat?
Well, people have to understand that challenging
an incumbent is not easy.
You will generally lose.
Um, but what we argue in this report is that,
uh, if you run a strong primary challenge
against a corporate democrat or a problematic
Democrat and you don't win, it still helps
you get progressive's organized within that
district.
It helps you win elections later and it puts
a scare into the incumbent to start serving
the interest of the constituents more than
the corporate donors.
So even if it's going to be a seat that ultimately,
uh, stays with the incumbent Democrat, there
are still specific reasons why it's valuable
to challenge, uh, some many or all of them,
no doubt about it.
That a forceful challenge is a success.
We've seen this so many places where you don't
knock out the incumbent Congress member, but
some of the activists who've learned electoral
skills, they then become members of the city
council or the county council.
It really helps build, and I'm not talking
about running 2% protest campaigns, I'm talking
about getting in the Democratic primary, running
a good campaign, learning the electoral skills.
Even if you don't knock out the incumbent,
it's still worthwhile.
So where my audience has some times disagreed
with my position on this is that I've said
I'm all about moving the Democratic Party
to the left.
I want to look at Senate seats.
I want to look at the House of Representatives.
I'm completely with you, but my pragmatic
side also recognizes that in a world of not
unlimited resources and there are some limits
in terms of how much money there is to be
invested in any particular state, district
or seat, there is some calculus to be made
about okay.
If we have the option of trying to primary
one Democrat versus trying to flip to red
seats to blue, that it's okay to make more
specific analyses of particular districts
and states and that sometimes the right answer
might be to leave a relatively centrist Democrat
be for some other goal that may be a higher
or more achievable or productive goal.
Is that General Calculus something that you
agree with or disagree with?
I agree with it up to a point.
Obviously progressive's in and their organizations
within a locale need to decide how best to
deploy those resources, but I began and the
whole organization Roots action.org began
in 2011 because we came to this conclusion,
there isn't just one problem facing our country,
which is the impression you get from Msnbc
and at certain news outlets, which is right
wing extremism.
Rightwing republicanism, we believe in equal
problem is that the Democratic Party leadership
is so corporatized and so in effective in
fighting for social, economic, racial, environmental
justice.
So if you begin with the idea that there are
two problems, sort of equal problems, uh,
then I think you and I would agree that sometimes
it makes sense to go after a Republican and
try to flip it.
But a lot of the times it makes sense to go
after the Corporate Democrat because frankly
in these, these bad blues, in this report
we just put out with 15 incumbents, that should
be primaried, 12 of them are in completely
democratic districts.
Five of them are in districts where the Democrats
win by 40 50, 70 points when you know Hillary
versus Trump.
Sure.
And if you don't primary a bad corporate problematic,
tired Democrat, you really have no congressional
election in your district, it doesn't exist.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
And I think that you're, it sounds like we
mostly agree.
I mean, I sometimes think about West Virginia
where you've got Joe Mansion, arguably the
most conservative Democrat in the Senate,
and you have three house congressional districts.
Uh, it's interesting, the idea of primary
and Joe Mansion at the same time.
When I look at, you know, the second district,
which is Alex Mooney's where he won by the
smallest margin of any of those three.
I don't know.
I mean, maybe it makes more sense to try to
flip that then to try to primary mansion given
the full calculus of the state's demographic,
you know, voting, voting demographics and
everything.
I don't know.
Like, is it crazy to think maybe the resources
are better spent trying to flip one of those
three congressional districts rather than
fighting mansion?
I'm not sure.
Yeah.
I'm not an expert on the three districts,
but I'm not arguing with your rationale that
progressive's need to be strategic.
I'm not for like Green party campaigns where
you went 2% of the vote and go, that's not
what we're talking about.
We're talking about running and pour a serious
progressive campaigns.
Uh, and, uh, in some places where there are
limited resources, you may be right.
Uh, but I have found as I travel around the
country, you know, I do vectors and I bring
out a crowd and there's a lot of activists
that, one of the great frustrations is people
that are saddled sometimes for 10, 20, 30
years with a Democratic Congress member in
a very blue district who's not getting the
job done, who's pro corporate, pro war and
uh, doesn't stand up to Trump.
And in those districts, if you're going to
have any kind of a congressional role as a
constituent, you're going to be running in
the Democratic primary against the incumbent.
So obviously in some districts that won't
make sense.
I would argue in many districts it does make
sense to primary a problematic democrat.
So the 15 that you've identified in the report,
is there some common thread in terms of political
positions that, oh, is, is visible across
all 15 that you believe is sort of the most
pernicious, uh, up, uh, element that makes
you say, these are the 15 we should target?
Yeah.
And remember we said at the BNA, the report,
the following report is far from exhaustive.
It's merely illustrative.
There's far more than the 15 that should be
primary.
But the 15 we profiled, yes.
I would say the one thread is corporatism.
These are people that when push comes to shove
side with corporate power over working class,
middle class, and poor people in their district.
Now there are some that are extreme.
I mean there are three on our list.
Schrader in Oregon, clay are in Texas and
Costa in California.
They get coke, brother money.
I mean there's so far right wing, they're
almost republicans.
But then there are the people that are like
makes mixes in a district, uh, in Queens where
Hillary beat Trump by 70 points and he's completely
a guide.
He's liberal on some issues, but he's completely
aligned with Wall Street.
That district should have a progressive and
so, but so the main thread I think is these
are people that when push comes to shove,
they identify with their corporate donors
and not middle class and working class people
broadly defined.
This is where I think the representatives
currently in the Democratic Party are furthest
from the electorate in the sense that over
the last 10 2025 years, you've seen the American
electorate in general move to the left on
a number of different issues.
Many of them are social, right?
So when you look at abortion, when you look
at gay marriage, when you look at the role
of religion in government, for example, but
on the corporate stuff, it seems as though
the difference between many Democrats and
almost all Republicans is so small compared
to where the Democratic voters are on this
issue.
Yeah, I agree with that 100% and a big issue
for us as war spending, I mean, Trump asked
for the biggest military budget in history
last year and he basically got it Polosi immediately
issued a statement, how she's working with
Trump to get the military spending.
You want Schumer issued a statement.
And what we found here is you've got a lot
of these Democrats who claim they want to
tighten the belts.
You know, they want to be fiscally conservative
because the Trump Trump is not, but they're
always for more military funding.
And so a big separating line as you say, is
corporate issues.
And another separating line is war issues.
I mean, one of the most vulnerable people
of the 15 is Elliot Angle.
He's the head of the House foreign affairs
committee.
But I'm foreign policy and war issues and
military spending.
He's with the Republicans.
I mean, remember most Democrats in the House
voted no on authorizing bushes, invasion of
Iraq, Elliot Angle of Bronx Westchester.
He voted yes with Bush.
Most Democrats were with Obama in the landmark.
Let's step away from war and let's have this
nuclear deal with Iran.
And Angle was one of the minority of Democrats
who voted with the Republicans against Obama's
nuclear deal.
When Trump says we're going to take this destabilizing,
he didn't say it was destabilizing, but it
was move of the you a US embassy in Israel
to Jerusalem angle is one of the Democrats
that immediately embraced this Trump.
So on now angle can be liberal on domestic
issues, but what really charges him up?
And the power he has in Washington is, he's
the head of the House foreign affairs committee,
but he, he basically has republican foreign
affairs views.
He should be out.
It's a completely democratic district.
But thinking about some of the strategy of
running some of these campaigns, I mean, what,
what is the right way to go about them?
Because often when you see national groups,
and I'm not pointing to your specifically,
but in other, in other cases, sometimes when
national groups make decisions about which
districts should be targeted for a, B or c
reasons, there is not a very genuine and authentic
feel to some of the primary challenges.
So what's the right way to run these races?
Well, it's, uh, it's complicated.
I mean, obviously roots action is part of
that mix.
We really respect Justice Democrats.
We respect working families party.
We respect our revolution and Progressive
Democrats of American Democratic Socialists
of America.
I mean, they've all played a in successful
campaigns.
Uh, Justice Democrats is so far endorsed in
two of our 15 districts.
They've endorsed, uh, against a choir in a
Texas and they've endorsed, uh, in New York.
Uh, I against, I think it's angle or minx
or makes the problem what not to do.
And this is a problem we're finding already
for 2020 is that in a number of these districts,
there's two progressive's that have gotten
into the race and two very strong progressive's
and that's a way that helps the democratic
corporate incumbent stay in office.
So we know what one thing not to do is split
up the progressive vote and as you've been
pointing out, split up progressive energy.
So, uh, that's where organizations are sort
of important early now in looking at the candidates
and deciding who's the most progressive, who
can win and or who is the most progressive,
who will run strong and then try to convince
people to rally around that one candidate.
I know it's often difficult because there's
often legitimate differences of opinion.
Very interesting report.
We'll be linking to the work of roots action.
Uh, in our, the description to the youtube
video for our interview, we've been speaking
with Jeff Cohen, who's a journalist, media
critic, founder of fairness and accuracy in
reporting and yeah,
cofounder of roots, action.
Jeff always great to talk to you.
Great to talk to you.
And they can find the report@badbluesdotorg